who'd you say is the greatest of all
time
can you can you make the case imagine
Kasparov can make the case for Kasparov
can make the case for Magnus Carlsen uh
Bobby Fischer
tall
in my opinion you can make a case for
Magnus Gary and Bobby Fischer I'm not
one of the folks that's like I mean
capablanca was brilliant you can argue
steinits was brilliant but that's
uh I think I think it was it's probably
Kasparov and Magnus has a chance to
overtake it
so the longevity is really important to
you when you're thinking about this yes
I think so I think Magnus is very very
close like it's it's extremely close
what will be the magic
you gotta get that sixth one
I'm just kidding so the World
Championships matter
it's kind of like basketball right Rings
it's all comes down to how many rings
did this person win what about well
basketball doesn't have this the number
of years is number one
right like uh rating sorry yeah uh like
there's a there is a
which is what Magnus really likes is
like there is a nice system of raiding
of who is ranked number one and has to
do not with some championships or low
sample Tournaments has to do with
General game after game after game helps
estimate more accurately the ELO rating
so yeah he's been world number one for I
think 11 years right which is still less
than because Harry was world number one
for 20 years yeah which is which is
quite wild but still lower rating I
think than Magnus now right yeah I think
rating in general has sort of allegedly
it got inflated yeah is that true is
there's true to that I think so I don't
I can't speak to how exactly it happened
but it also happens online if you go
back just three or four years I think
some of the best Blitz players on let's
say shows.com were 27 2800 and now
they're 3200 I think it's just sort of
what happens but I
I don't exactly know uh I will mention
that there was a very strange change not
exactly sure when the year was in fide
so over the board chess where if you
were
under the age of 16 or 18 years old one
of those two
and you were below 2300
okay
your rating change Factor was three to
four times higher
so just imagine that means Magnus has a
rating change factor of of let's say one
I have a reading change Factor also of
one anybody over the rating 2400 has the
same rating change Factor uh what is uh
the rating change Factor so if you win
yeah there's a formula and basically
let's say at the very base level five
point change if your rating change
factor is one you beat somebody you gain
five points
those kids who were under 18 and under
2300 the rating change Factor was four
so their ratings were going out four
times higher and four times like up and
down compared to normal folks and there
was a there was one teenager in the US
in particular who in one month
played a bunch of tournaments with his
rating change Factor
and became nearly rated 2640.
which is top 50 in the world it was just
a random teenager from the United States
he became a grand master ultimately but
he bled like 90 points down because his
rating was so inflated and this the k-40
exists now I mean you have many kids who
out of nowhere 2100 2100 2400 after you
know one good month
like what so that's interesting that's
like uh similar to like how Tick Tock
inflates your virality
early on
well yeah like I I and well at least the
rumor is like they want you to get
engaged and I thought there was even
artificial likes and so on that they
want you to get that dopamine addiction
so maybe they want to throw you if
you're really passionate about Chess
they want you to throw you to the Sharks
by artificially inflating you inflating
your rating and maybe that gets you into
the game much more intensely Maybe
fair I wonder how many like backdoor
feeding meetings there are with cigars
and so that that was uh the factors
determined by who who does the the ELO
rating who changes this stuff yeah
who knows it's probably those Lee chess
anarchists yeah exactly I think they
wanna
I think they wanna they wanna stay away
from that stuff